i'm aware that uh it's it's basically a
very rare uh disease and um
so far the consequences don't seem to be
uh very serious but we it's important
that we keep an eye on it and
that's exactly what the uh the new uk uh
health security agency is doing some
countries though we're looking at
quarantine for visitors looking at the
small air pocks vaccines is that
something we should be considering too i
think that
as things stand the the judgment is that
it's it's rare
uh i think we're looking very carefully
at the circumstances of uh transmission
um
it hasn't yet
it hasn't yet proved faithful in any
case that that we know certainly not in
this uh in this country uh the the uk
health security agency new uh body is is
obviously following very closely okay
let's talk about sue gray
what did you talk about in your secret
meeting last month i'm with great
respect not going to
comment or give any running commentary
on
her report until we get it and
i i think that
to be frank the moment is not very far
off um it can't be long now before i'll
be able to say something but i really
want to wait as i've said a long time
now until suitable did you initiate that
meeting though i'm not giving any
running commentary on
the process
in any way
until
the independent uh report is is produced
but that is that i think that is that is
reasonable uh i've been asked to comment
uh on all sorts of things over the last
uh few months uh we're here to we're
here for instance to
talk about
the incredible national tutoring program
that we love to tell people i've helped
help pupils catch up from from kobe and
it's going gangbusters and here in this
school at uh some mary cray in orpington
they're giving kids uh tutoring uh
one-on-one or one to
three one to two it makes a huge
difference when i was a primary school
in london i benefited massively from a
teacher that took a a direct personal
interest in me i know what a difference
it can make and i think that the
the tutoring program is something that
will give
tutoring which you know some some some
parents have it anyway they they buy it
in but this will this will give
kids who don't normally have access to
that kind of direct personal
uh interest care
um
and
for me it's leveling up it's giving it's
giving kids opportunity that they
wouldn't otherwise so what we want to do
is is to get from if you can think about
it at 11 the year six
65 of our kids and our pupils currently
have uh good enough reading writing
mathematics we want to get that up to 90
now imagine the change for our country
if you go from 65
to 90
it would be absolutely transformational
for
chances of people growing up in this
country just one more question on sue
gray you say the report independence
many people say she reports to you
fundamentally and you've met with her
can you really claim not asking for the
report but is the report still
independent of course and but on on the
the process you're just going to have to
hold your
horses a little bit longer i don't
believe it will be too much longer and
then i'll be able to say a bit more one
final topic that's the cost of living
crisis are you ideologically opposed to
a windfall tax is it unconservative a
windfall tax
plenty of uh i don't like new taxes
and i think it's very important that we
focus on investment and jobs now the
reason we're in a strong position to
help people is because we've got
unemployment at the lowest level since
1970
when i was in a primary school like this
so uh
that's a that's massively important and
it enables us to
use our fiscal firepower our taxpayers
money to help people and we're going to
continue uh to do that so it's not on
conservative no option is off the table
let's be absolutely clear about that i'm
not attracted uh intrinsically to new
taxes but as i've said throughout we've
got to do what we can
and we will to look after people
through the aftershocks of of coded uh
through the current uh pressures on
energy prices that we're seeing uh post
covenant with what's going on in in
russia and we're going to put our arms
around people just as we did during the
panic and just very finely on that you
you said at the queen speech
day that you're going to make an article
within days it's now nearly two weeks
later when are we going to hear
something about what the government's
doing cost of living
we're
already don't forget what we've already
done 22 billion pounds we've already put
in
uh to help people uh the
9.1 billion to help with energy costs
150 pounds off your
of your council tax uh increased uh
warm homes alliance and uh and of course
the
cut in uh national insurance
contributions which on average will be
worth 330 pounds for for somebody uh on
on average early so 330 pounds cut in in
ni that comes in in july so there's a
continuing stream of effort but more to
come to shield people and of course this
thing is going to go on everybody can
see the uh the the increase in energy
prices uh there is more that we're going
to do but you know again you just have
to
you'll just have to wait a little bit
longer thank you thank you